me and Sam are here Sam you wrote
something at the top of this I want to
hear what you have to say which is
people's reply about what we talked
about last time Gracia let's jump in
with that all right you want to I'm
gonna read just word for word I have it
pulled up on my Twitter okay you ready
I'm not gonna read the guy's name he
goes I'm a modest-sized mid seven-figure
Amazon seller and a network of guys that
range from 1 or 2 million to probably 50
million plus we have a few guys in our
network that actually sold their company
to throw out how do you call it
gracias yeah de Rossi oh happy to chat
about Amazon ecommerce sometime ok so
I'm gonna read his replies now for those
of you listening the background is is
that on Tuesday Sean and I had talked
about the ratio it's a company that
raised money they raised 100 200 million
at a 750 valuation I don't remember yeah
close to a hundred million at Amelia dog
nation a big company you can they're
only tears old there and what they're
doing is buying Amazon Fulfillment and
filled by Amazon company fulfilled by
Amazon companies and they are making the
brands better and just owning them
they're doing a bunch of stuff and so I
had a guy reach out to me and he's I go
that's great
tell me what's the I asked him what's
the cash flow situation like for most
guys sub ten million dollars they're
probably working with zero to a handful
of US employees still actively involved
in the day-to-day large team in the
Philippines and in cheap locations and
are probably netting between 10 to 20
percent a year and and so the typical
size for 3 to 5 million the typical size
is 3 to 5 million in revenue and they're
probably pulling in 500 to a million
dollars a year for themselves but the
problem is is that it's getting harder
and harder in 2013 you could sell almost
anything and scale seven figure business
now there are a lot more dominant more
sophisticated players and it's
incredibly hard to enter in the business
the Amazon algorithm is much smarter and
it makes
making incredibly expensive and
difficult also Amazon treats their
sellers like trash so it's kind of a
mixed bag I could take a month and do
nothing and let my team run it and it
can go perfect or I can get an email
tomorrow saying my account has been
suspended or killed and I need a lawyer
to reinstate everything or I'm just
crushed
so anyway Sean I wanted to fill you in
on this because I thought it was cool
inside I didn't know about yeah that's
that's a good insight so a couple of
thoughts on that so the first is I think
he's right you know back 2013-2014 it
was a lot easier to do it than it is
today that seems consistent with what
I've heard in fact it seems like the
formula is build a successful Amazon
business in 2013 14 15 then start
teaching other people how to do it
because it's too hard to do anymore and
so now you start giving away the sort of
secrets and you become a TV for the next
three years so I think that's the the
career path right now the other thing
that comes to mind we were talking I was
talking to Andrew Wilkinson about this
and he was saying he used the I think
it's a it's a Charlie Munger quote which
I oh no it's a Nassim Taleb quote which
is it's like picking up pennies in front
of a steamroller so the you know there's
a high probability you can make a little
bit of money um you know consistently
every single time you reach down and you
pick it up and then there's you know a
low probability of complete death and
that's what he's talking about when he
says you can get a letter tomorrow that
says your account is suspended goodbye
and and that's it or Amazon cuts the
rates of your category like I have a
friend who was doing millions of dollars
of book sales as a third party book
seller on Amazon and the name was almost
like you know what
now our take rate on books has you know
not 10% we're gonna do 25% things and
that like killed that happened to me
this that happened to me the other day
so in our we have in the trends group
someone was like just so you know Amazon
changed the feet so basically I have
various blogs like my personal blog or
something like that and it makes just
like small amounts of money like three
to five thousand dollars a month off
Amazon affiliates and I don't even check
it it just runs because because I write
just written a lot of content over the
years they changed their rate and
someone told me in the
I think I forget what I was
earning I don't even check it I think I
was earning 6% to 9% for affiliate
revenue and then they changed it to they
like halved it so that money just haft
and it's no big deal because it wasn't a
bit it wasn't like a big income stream
for me but if you're a wire cutter or if
you're BuzzFeed and you made a hundred
million dollars from this it's a huge
deal
right yeah that that 20% cut makes it
makes a really big difference no no no
it wasn't at all it wasn't a 20% cut it
was way bigger than that it was like
half they have out and what category are
your links mostly and is it electronics
is it some cat is one category was just
across the board they rate they lowered
it across categories but across the
board it's close to half my categories
were probably personal care and
electronics I mean just anyone who ya
I'm booked a lot of books right okay I
want to know another topic so we're good
on terasi oh you want to add anything
else no you do not want to know I think
it's it's consistent with what we
thought you know I like when people fill
in the gaps with information that we
don't have I'm not an FBA seller I don't
know the ins and outs of that market I
just think it's interesting we talked a
little bit about it and then people fill
in the gaps in the next episode we come
back a little smarter that's a nice
little formula we have going so I
appreciate that
or you ever talk about stuff you know
tell us that was more about what what
you know that we don't
[Music]